I ended up without time for this story
yesterday but it is important and I did
want to talk about it with you so two
days ago Donald Trump during what was
day three officially our although kind
of day two as we knew it but officially
day three on Wednesday of his Senate
impeachment trial he went on Twitter and
he appeared to admit to concealing
evidence which is an example of
obstructing Congress which is something
he's already being impeached for this is
Donald Trump speaking from the World
Economic Forum in Davos Switzerland this
is the same place where he went after 17
year old climate activists Greta tun
Berg which we discussed on yesterday's
program Trump talking about how he has
the material and they meaning Democrats
the house impeachment Managers don't
have the material which means he's
concealing evidence if he's indeed
telling the truth here when we released
that conversation all hell broke out
with the Democrats because they say wait
a minute this is much different than
shifty Schiff told us so we're doing
very well I got to watch enough I
thought our team did a very good job but
honestly we have all the material they
don't have the material we have the
material they don't have the material if
we're understanding Donald Trump and if
he's telling the truth it's always
possible with Trump that either were not
understanding him because he's difficult
to understand or that he's simply lying
he seems to be admitting to withholding
evidence from house impeachment managers
and by the way Donald Trump also lying
in that clip for sure even though it's
only 23 seconds Donald Trump also
managing to lie and again falsely
claimed that he released the phone
called transcript he did not release the
phone call transcript the phone call was
about 30 33 minutes long going from
memory the transcript portion that was
released seemed to consist of somewhere
between six and nine minutes of that 30
to 33 minute phone call but he keeps
repeating and his attorneys keep
repeating and Republicans keep repeating
we saw the transcript and it was fine
and it was a perfect phone call they did
not and it wasn't and we would love
see the transcript and by the way I
would love to hear audio of the perfect
phone call but back to the material that
Donald Trump has this is their strategy
and they've been rewarded for this
strategy we talked about this a lot on
yesterday's program they've ignored
subpoenas simply saying we're not going
to do it
he's crediting the strategy of ignoring
subpoenas and withholding material as
the reason why he's doing well in the
impeachment trial every single time
Congress requests something Trump and
his lawyers Stonewall or they just don't
do it they're asked to produce documents
they don't they try to block witnesses
they try to prevent witnesses from
testifying this is obstruction of
Congress which Donald Trump is bragging
about doing and he's doing it in order
to obstruct an impeachment trial
partially for obstructing Congress I I
guess the upside is if you're already
impeached for obstruction of Congress
you can't be double impeached for
obstruction of Congress I don't know and
the sickest part is that it's going to
work
Trump is don't care about Donald Trump
actually being exonerated in a fair
trial we talked about how on day one of
actually before day one well depends on
what you call day one but before opening
arguments even started you had both
Donald Trump's lawyers and House
impeachment managers saying for this to
really carry weight for an acquittal
earner or a conviction to really mean
something it needs to be a full and fair
trial and and if you're the house
impeachment managers that means it has
to include documents it has to include
witnesses and the reality is they're
wrong Trump doesn't care about actually
having a fair trial because Trump ists
don't care about having a fair trial
they will see a kangaroo court return a
sham acquittal we learned 40% of
Republicans weren't even in the chamber
during much of Adam shifts opening
arguments two days ago they will see
this bogus sham acquittal that's been
preconceived already and they will
consider it an exoneration even though
Donald Trump's handling of his
impeachment is our
impeachable and he'll be acquitted and
potentially reelected in November of
2020
just look at what's happened before he
admitted to obstructing justice on
national television and on Twitter
nothing happened we say this guy appears
to be untouchable and he seems to
actually be right he believes he's
untouchable and so far he's been
untouchable he publicly intimidates
witnesses on Twitter and through
subordinates tampering with witnesses
gets away with it he sees himself as
untouchable because he's been
effectively untouchable and the only
thing to do I mean it's an indictment of
our justice system sorry it's an
indictment of the state of checks and
balances but the only thing we have left
is to vote in November as I said
yesterday in such large numbers that it
would be difficult to manipulate into a
Trump win period the chance of an
indictment essentially ended when
impeachment began it's sad it's horrible
to admit these Republicans won't even
consider it I was hoping maybe you know
when we hear there might be five
Republicans who might might be willing
to do the right thing and maybe they
could convince others it's just not
going to be what the Republican Party
cares to do here it's it's not
we've lost checks and balances the only
one left is an O it's not just a win in
November it has to be an overwhelming
win so overwhelming that foul play and
tricks and interference and voting
machine nonsense and all of it
can't get him reelected and once again
I'm opening of the floor if you think
there's any chance of a conviction in
this Senate trial I want to hear from
you I don't know if there's anyone left
in my audience who thinks we might see a
conviction here I saw that the betting
odds at one point had about twelve
percent of the money saying there could
be there will be a conviction that was
down to seven percent a couple days ago
I don't know where it is right now if
there's anyone in my audience who thinks
we might see a conviction by all means
please get in touch and tell me what
will happen I know that the David Pakman
show audience is full of curious and
creative people who love learning new
things and bettering themselves and
that's why I'm so excited to tell you
about one of our sponsors Skillshare the
vibrant online learning come
that offers thousands of classes on
almost any topic you can imagine and
you'll get full access to the entire
library of classes for two entire months
free when you go to david pakman.com
slash skill all of the classes are
taught by experts in their fields
they've got classes on drawing painting
photography video editing web design
bookkeeping marketing personal
productivity doesn't even scratch the
surface I recently took a class about
photography if anybody follows me on
instagram you know that my photography
skills leave much to be desired and it
was great I got so much out of it and
hopefully you will see the fruits of me
taking that class reflected in my
Instagram pictures sooner than later
they have classes for every skill level
whether you're wanting to get better at
something you already have experience
with you want to learn something totally
new to you you set your own pace classes
are usually less than an hour long
they're divided up into bite-size
segments so you can easily fit them into
your schedule make 2020 a year where you
explore new skills deep in existing
passions get lost in creativity
Skillshare really makes it easier than
ever Skillshare memberships are less
than ten bucks a month and that gives
you access to the thousands of classes
they offer but everybody in the David
Pakman show audience gets a Skillshare
membership totally free for two whole
months just go to david pakman.com slash
skill that's david pakman.com slash s ki
ll